hi guys it's ria welcome to tasty's hot
or hustle on this show tasty producers
make a dish
using bunch of different hacks collected
by
our friends ani in the past episode i
made
cake and cookies and today i'm making my
favorite thing
pie i love making pie my name is almost
pie
i'm the perfect person to do this
episode i know a couple hacks
but i would like to up my baking pie
game
we have control pie right here this
recipe
is from evan clyman one of my food hero
so this is a classic apple pie with
all butter crust we use the sliced
apples
granny smith as a filling brushed with
egg wash
we use crimping technique so it look
like
emoji apple pie alright let's get
started
so the first hack is the hack i always
use when i make pie
put all ingredients and utensils in the
freezer
when you're making dough sometimes you
melt
butter and that is one thing you don't
want to do that when you're making pie
so i put all the utensils and
ingredients in the freezer
so whenever i'm touching and kneading
dough
butter is still solid so next hack
use shortening instead of all butter
so shoning is vegetable based
fat i normally don't want to use
shortening
because i don't like eating it it
doesn't have any flavor
when you use shonen it is easier to roll
and hand during pile because when you
are using all butter
sometimes it is like falling apart and
its difficult to
shape or roll we have another hack
you do the processor when you're mixing
dough so when you are making pie dough
you can use those kind of torture
devices but
when you use food processor it is easier
and all the ingredients is super cold
i'm going
to put butter and shortening and puffs
and also you kind of want to make a
butter chunk like a pea
side so next hack follow your gut
when you are adding water when you're
making pie
a lot of recipe book says out of this
much water
but i never use the amount in a recipe i
always use less water you use the amount
in a recipe sometimes the texture is not
right
so next hack is adding vodka
in the dough so when you add water into
flour and knead it it will create gluten
but alcohol prevents that and also helps
make
dough flakier this hacks is
perfect for me because i always use
alcohol for my cooking
magnum side sake
all right so next hack is adding apple
cider vinegar
so vinegar will help preventing gluten
foaming
and also i feel like it kind of gives
good flavor
and start foaming the dough and you
don't want to touch too long
because you don't want to melt pea
butter
it's p e a not p you can see those like
little butter bits
it's a good sign of pie and you're going
to
divide this in half you want to
shape like a flat disc so it's
easier to roll when you're rolling and
i'm going to
rest and chill this dough in a
refrigerator
while i'm making filling right
so next hack instead of using one type
of apple use
combination of apples for this apple pie
i'm using honey crisp and granny smith
granny smith is a great apple for apple
pie but
sometimes it's a little bit too tart i
have honey crisp
honey crisp is a little bit sweeter side
i don't think you want to use
gala because gala is mushy so next hack
is peeling hack use this torture device
to peel
apple ah ow i cut it i didn't know there
was a blade
so this is a not a great style for this
hack so i've
never used this before oh
wow okay wow look
i think this is great tool but
i don't want to have tools that only
have
one purpose but if you're making apple
pies all the time i think this is very
good tool okay
so next hack is from chef thomas keller
he's one of the greatest american chef
and he said
dice half apple and grate half apple the
grated apple
cooks faster so it kind of gives nice
apple saucy texture and diced
apple gives you bites usually i
only slice apples like quarter inch
but if you like a little bit softer
texture
i think this is a good hug and the next
hack is
use tapioca flour instead of cornstarch
or
flour so when you use cornstarch or
flour the filling
becomes a little bit cloudy when you
finish baking but tapioca
flour makes it clear and i'm going to
add brown sugar
and pinch of salt and one teaspoon
of cinnamon the reason we maserate with
flour it's kind of like marinating you
kind of want to incorporate spice and
sugar in the filling so we are going to
leave this about 30 minutes
so next hug use apple cider adding
more intense apple flavor and i'm going
to reduce
until like maple syrup texture i
didn't know this hack so i'm excited to
see it okay
so it is reduced i want to try because
it looks
like maple syrup it's delicious it's
like apple candy
i have dough and the next hack roll
dough in between piece of wax paper
used this hash before but i use
parchment paper
i think both works usually people just
like
dust flour on a rolling pin and
surface so another hack is when you want
to roll
perfect circle instead of rolling
only one direction you want to rotate it
a little bit
kind of makes me dizzy when you're
rolling
pie dough start cracking but i feel like
this shortening is working i usually use
all butter crust recipe and if i
do what i did just now sometimes it's
cracks
i think shortening definitely helps i'm
still skeptical about
flavor when i make pine usually it has
bits of butter and flour all over and
it's
kind of annoying to clean but if you use
parchment or wax paper
there's less dishes you have to do so
i'd use this hack
you're gonna use all the juice i'm going
to
add apple cider reduction
when i rolled the bottom part i used wax
paper hack so
now i'm gonna just use flour just see
the comparison so you're gonna just
dust your surface with flour i
made pie video with local kitchen she
makes
beautiful pie and what i learned at the
shoe
she was kind of putting flour once in a
while
when you're rolling as you can see there
will be no flour
and if you keep rolling it will stick to
the surface
so next hack from tasty video we are
going to use cookie cutter
and make pretty patterns so i have this
flower shape
cookie cutter now i knew how important
your thumb is
i feel like i'm a cat without whiskers i
think they lose the
direction so like whisker is very
important for cats
cake now i'm going to
transfer this layer on top of the pie
extra hack you're folding top layer pie
dough
into quarter this way it's very easy to
transfer
and you can easily find the center so
next hack
i'm using scissors to cut
excess dough and i'm gonna tuck this
under
next hug is use fork to crimp the pie
i think it's cute it's hot it's kind of
nice like rustic
pattern i finished crimping and
next hack use heavy cream to
give nice golden matte finish
i don't know if i want matte finish i
like those
egg wash effect so we will see use
top-notch sugar
to give a nice crunchy texture on the
pie
and i use this hack so i like this hack
last hack use sheet pan when you're
baking pie
i think this is very necessary actually
when you are baking
especially apple pie this is something i
highly recommend you to do i definitely
do it at home because the juice spills
all over
more like you must do it pie is ready
let's bake this
and see what's gonna happen
so my hak pie is baked and cold
and here is our control pie i like
shiny finish on egg wash kind of a
little bit dull
it doesn't give any shine but i like
topping out the sugar
kind of gives nice texture i think
cookie cutter
maybe looks prettier when you're making
cherry pie or blueberry pie
let's see crimping i like
classic looking of this i also
love pie crust so i like
this thick crimping so i can eat more
crust
so let's taste test so folk crimping
is kind of stuck
in a pie so i cannot give a nice
slice and now i'm going to slice control
pie
so what i noticed is tapioca starch
definitely give nice clear juice
so i like that as you can see control we
use
flour so it's kind of crowdy let's taste
it
so we talk about when we use tapioca
flour for filling but
actually flavor wise i like tapioca
starch
better this one we use flour
and we kind of have like floury
taste and we grated apple
and we diced the apple apple chunk holds
up so
it gives nice crunchy texture
grated apple it still has a bite too
it definitely depends on your preference
i
like apple feeling better i think it's
because of apple cider it's a little bit
sweeter
contour pie we only use granny smith and
it's a little bit
tart so i feel like i want something a
little bit sweeter
so for hakpai we used shonen with butter
so let's see how that changes flavor
if i was blind folded and taste tested
i don't taste any difference between all
butter crust
and shortening i still have slight doubt
about
shoning so when i make pie i will
definitely use
all butter crust but if you are not
afraid of
using shonening i think it is good hack
to use
so here are my three favorite hacks from
today one
add vodka to pie crust two use
two different kinds of apples three use
tapioca starch
instead of flour thank you so much for
watching and thank you so much for
following along
my pie journey if you know more pie
hacks please comment below
and thank you for watching and don't cut
your thumb
[Music]
bye
you